We're about to play a game
called "Box of Lies,"
but I'm going to need some help.
She is this week's musical guest
on "Saturday Night Live,"
and her album
"Red (Taylor's Version)"
is out at midnight tonight.
Please welcome Taylor Swift!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello.
-[ Chuckles ]
Thank you so much for --
Taylor, get ready to play --
We've never played this game,
have we?
-We have not played this game.
-No, we've played
a bunch of games,
but this one is a new one.
Here we go.
Now, here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box.
Take out the object.
Describe the object
to your opponent, okay?
And they have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
I mean, and, you know,
I'm not that good
of an actor, so...
-That's ridiculous.
Don't say things like that.
That's your first lie.
Immediately know.
-Why don't you choose
the first box?
Any one. Any number you'd like.
-Okay.
-[ Humming ]
Oh, number one. Okay.
-Big shock.
-Yeah, yeah.
Oh, look at this.
Not that heavy,
so that's the first hint.
All right. Here we go. Yeah.
-[ Gasps ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Oh, my God.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-Where do I put it?
-You can put it
here in the front.
I won't see it.
Are you going to lie to me...
or are you going to tell
the truth, Taylor Swift?
-I don't have to lie because
I'm very excited to tell you
that it is
a "Wizards of Waverly Place" DVD
with a weird ribbon around it
that says, "I see corn."
-So specific.
It sounds like something
our writers would do,
but then you're delivering it
very innocent.
Which makes me think that
you're maybe...making it up.
Now you're laughing that I said
you're making it up.
-I could be doing
a double bluff.
-All right.
I'm just going to say it.
Taylor Swift, you are...
telling the truth.
-I lied!
-[ Buzzer ]
-Aah!
Come on!
Oh, my God.
-I lied.
-You lied.
You did it.
-I lied.
-Oh, my God.
-I have a binoculars set
with corn stuffed in it.
It's very upsetting.
It has baby corn at the top.
It's bad.
-I'm sorry.
-You should have known
I was lying
because I will do anything
to bring up Selena Gomez.
Anything!
-I want to --
It's my turn to pick.
Which number shall I pick?
[ Audience shouting ]
Here we go.
[ Grunting ]
-Ah. Okay. This is excellent.
This is really rough.
What's happening over here?
Okay.
-[ Panting ] Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Where -- Where do I begin?
Uh...
-It's a good one.
-Yeah.
-It's a family of pinecones
playing "Trouble."
-The game?
-No. The song.
-It'd be relevant.
-"I Knew You Were Trouble."
It would be relevant for "Red."
-It would be relevant.
-That's what I'm feeling.
-I just didn't know if they had
the sheet music for it
or something.
-Whatever it is, it's odd.
It's weird and it's real.
Or am I lying?
-Um, well, maybe you're telling
the truth about the pinecone...
-♪ Trouble, trouble, trouble ♪
-Okay.
[ Drum roll ]
You tell the truth.
-[ Buzzer ]
-I got you!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
-Ahh!
[ Giggling ] Whoo! Whoo!
That felt good.
Man, I'm exhausted.
-That was amazing.
You should be.
-I don't act.
I don't know how to act.
-No, you do.
-Don't know how to act.
-Either that, or we're, like,
the worst poker players,
the worst -- We should never --
We shouldn't be allowed outside.
-We really shouldn't
be allowed outside.
-Too gullible.
-We're too gullible.
-Yeah.
-But you know what?
But here we go.
This is the last one.
This is for all the marbles
right here.
-Yeah.
-Taylor, you're up. Here we go.
Come on. Which one?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Three? All right.
I'm not looking.
Not looking. Not looking.
Not hearing. Not listening.
We can still make noise.
So I don't cheat.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know what's happening.
-Okay.
♪♪
I've got in my vision...
um, a book.
[ Laughter ]
A b-- A book called, um,
"I'm Not Loving It: My Life
Under the Golden Arches,"
and it looks like it's
a biography written by, um...
-Ray Kroc?
-...by a fuzzy monster
with, um, seal hands.
Um, it says
it's written by Grimace.
Is that -- Is that -- Is that
a spokesperson for something?
-It's very famous.
Grimace is very --
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're very young, Taylor.
But, yes, Grimace is giant.
We don't know really
what Grimace was.
Is he purple where you are?
-It's actually
a black-and-white cover.
It's a very serious book.
Um, inside the book, it's --
You know how you can cut out
the pages of a book?
-Sure. I know that.
-Yeah, there's French fries
and a hamburger in here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
Taylor Swift...
[ Drum roll ]
You tell the truth.
-I do.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh! Taylor Swift!
That was stressful. Oh, my gosh.
I have to take -- I'm taking
that home, by the way.
You can take that home.
-It smells delicious.
-You can have that.
Yeah. You can have that.
Taylor Swift, everybody.